[Music]
this pandemic has shown us how
vulnerable we all are
whether it's india where the number of
cases is currently skyrocketing with
over 300 000 new infections a day
or in europe which has reported the
highest death toll for a long time
and where vaccination is still very slow
everywhere in the world resources to
fight the virus are limited
that is why there are priority lists for
vaccination
first we must protect those most at risk
but are we really doing that what about
children
they're way down at the bottom of any
priority list besides
there's not even a vaccine available for
them yet
that leaves children with special needs
especially vulnerable
[Music]
welcome to our kobe 19 special i'm
monica jones and berlin good to have you
with us
and you just have to admire kids and
their ability to deal with new
situations
isaac kids every day on their way to
school or in supermarkets with their
parents
and they're wearing their little face
masks with such ease as
if it was the most natural thing in the
world but not every child can adapt that
easily
and for some this virus is an additional
risk to an already challenging life
physical exercises are important
especially for flavia
the 14 year old has down syndrome
normally
she doesn't do them with her mother but
her physiotherapist
but since the coronavirus pandemic
started the family has severely
restricted their contacts because for
flavia
a coveted infection could be fatal
an infection booked by a mention with
down syndrome
for people with down syndrome an
infection habers
much greater risks than for others
additionally
we know very little about long-term
effects of this illness
so even if she were to survive an
infection we wouldn't know
what would come after that
therefore the family keeps to themselves
physical contact with others is
restricted
the children are only occasionally
allowed to play with others
school happens online all of this puts a
strain on flavia
i cried quite a bit because school was
closed
so we had to do it digitally and that
was stressful
[Music]
we've noticed that flavia suffers
enormously from this loneliness
she sits in her room for hours she talks
to herself
more and more she makes noises she just
isolates herself
and [ __ ] getting flavia vaccinated
against covered would help the family
but no vaccine has yet been approved for
under 16 year olds in germany
clinical trials are still ongoing
in these trials different age groups are
tested under close observation
that way the researchers can gradually
find out how the drug reacts with
certain groups but they haven't finished
that yet so
using the vaccine now is a bit like
walking into a dark
forest so to speak and don't invite
them the family hopes that this dark
forest will clear
soon they don't know when the
vaccination will be approved for
children
until then they will do everything they
can to protect their daughter
for more i'm joined by dr anker hools
she's assistant professor of
epidemiology and environmental health
at the roland school of public health at
emory university in atlanta good to have
you with us
please tell us first of all how much do
we actually know
about covet 19 in patients with ds
hi monica thanks a lot for having me um
yeah so
up to now we so the trisomy 21 research
society
um conducted a large scale study on
individuals with down syndrome and kovi
19
and what we found when investigating
more than 1 000 individuals with down
syndrome and kobe 19
is that individuals with down syndrome
are much more likely to die after having
kovi 19 than the general population
so for example individuals with down
syndrome
and kovit 19 so their mortality rates
when they are 40 are comparable to those
from the general population who are 70.
so they are the mortality risk is much
higher than
the general population why why is that
what puts them at
such high risk so
that is different reasons so um one
thing
is that individuals with down syndrome
in general
often suffer from premature aging so for
example
individuals with down syndrome are also
very likely to develop dementia at a
very young age so
in their 40s many of them already have
dementia
and another reason is that they also
often suffer from
from immune dysfunction so as an example
individuals with down syndrome are also
um they are known to be more vulnerable
to
all kinds of respiratory disease and
pneumonia for example
so it's unfortunately it's it's not
surprising that they are also more
vulnerable to
kobe 19. right so when when the mother
in this
report that we just saw says she's she's
terribly worried about her daughter
you just basically agreed that she has
every right to be
that worried how can she better protect
her
yeah so first of all i really want to
highlight that
the high mortality rates that he um
observed among individuals with down
syndrome
were particularly present for the um
nebulous with down syndrome above the
age of 40.
so we only found very
few um deaths among children with down
syndrome so it was really really rare
which is similar
as in the general population so that's
at least one
good thing but of course nevertheless
that doesn't mean that
parents of individuals with down
syndrome don't have to worry
because as i already mentioned death is
not the only adverse outcome of this
disease and we still
know so little about the long-term
effects of kobe 19
and also other respiratory complications
might be more prevalent among children
with down syndrome
than among children without down
syndrome so of course it is important to
protect them
but the other problem is that it's also
um yeah it's a hard thing to do and a
hard decision because
especially kids with down syndrome they
they as we already so saw in the video
um
we we they really need um a special care
not only for their physical health but
also for their cognitive and mental
health
so it's always an act of balancing the
risks and benefits and at the moment our
highest chance to really protect them
is vaccination vaccination i know that
in the united states
teenagers at least from the age of 16
onwards
uh can now be vaccinated does this
include
teenagers with down syndrome
yes absolutely so in december
the cdc included arsenal down syndrome
was a high risk
medical complication for kobe 19. so
and and then in january when when the
last sky rollout started
most states included individuals with
down syndrome
and their first or second priority group
so and since mid march early april
the whole country and the whole country
individuals with down syndrome
can be vaccinated against copay 19
and that includes all um yeah also
teenagers so starting at the age of 16.
and i know that um most european
countries
now are not now also vaccinating
individuals with down syndrome because
it is
now well known that they are at a higher
risk for severe kobe 19.
so um so many european countries also
vaccinate any deals with down syndrome
starting at the age of 16.
all right so now uh we have to look
forward to that and of course to
vaccines
for children that are even younger than
that uh but for now thank you so much dr
anker hills from the rowland school of
public health at
emory university in atlanta thank you so
much for your time
thank you for having me bye
and of course we all hope that
vaccination will bring back the freedoms
we've enjoyed before the pandemic for
some sooner than others perhaps
time to ask derek
will germany or the eu be implementing a
coveted vaccine passport
yes though it won't be called that as
it'll also
document people who've had the disease
or have
recorded recent negative tests um the eu
is moving forward
with what's being called a digital green
certificate
to facilitate movement within the block
though it's still
not yet clear exactly what rights
it'll confer there's opposition of
course
but but but proponents say governments
currently really have few
other options after all long before the
pandemic hit
tourism had become a key pillar for for
nearly
every economy on earth and and the last
15 months
have just cut the industry off at the
ankles
europe relies on tourism heavily and and
desperate attempts
to to restart it somehow some way
have been going on since the very first
days of lockdown
over a year ago um so so what are the
issues
well there are many ethical questions
but a lot of critics think the most
serious
is that a certificate could lead to
discrimination
against people who for whatever reason
haven't been vaccinated or at least not
yet
especially if the documents are used
to limit their activities in their own
countries
by their own governments there are also
big practical and technological barriers
to overcome in implementing
certification
systems especially when it comes to to
data privacy
and security um potential fraud is
another big issue
despite the many hurdles the plan is to
have the program
up and running by june in order to make
travel between
eu member states easier for people
who are vaccinated or who have recovered
and
and
not just for europeans talks have also
begun
with the us about the best ways to allow
fully vaccinated or recovered american
tourists
to begin returning to europe
[Music]
that's all for today thanks for watching